les hôpitaux qui arrive en saturation
avec un nombre de malades en réanimation
plus conséquent que le nombre de places
disponibles en ile de france
l'urgence est donc de trouver de
nouveaux lits d'ouvrir de nouveaux lits
et aussi à la production de respirateurs
artificiels pour les équiper l usine psa
de poissy se joint à l'effort du moment
l'entreprise a répondu à l'appel
d'offres d'air liquide
objectif produire et 10000 respirateur
d'ici mai 60 salariés des 3500 du site
dont donc assemblés sur place est des
composants mécaniques qui seront ensuite
envoyés à l'usiné
air liquide antony dans les
hauts-de-seine écoutez les explications
du directeur industriel de psa
face à cette situation exceptionnelle
notre entreprise s'est mobilisée d'une
part un groupe de travail d'une
trentaine d'experts à étudier la
meilleure façon de produire les
respirateurs plus rapidement et en
grande quantité en parallèle dans la
mesure où dans notre usine de poissy
nous avons mis en place les mesures de
sécurité sanitaire renforcée pour
protéger nos salariés nous avons décidé
d'y installer un atelier pour produire
le bloc central des respirateurs
artificiels et puis enfin des salariés
volontaires du groupe vont aussi
rejoindre les ateliers d'air liquide
pour prêter main forte à l'assemblage
des respirateurs les salariés impliqués
sont tous volontaires et leur dossier
médical leur permet un retour à l'usiné
ils sont d'ores et déjà engagés comme le
précise le délégué psa poissy de force
ouvrière qui restera tout de même
vigilant sur la sécurité des salariés
aujourd'hui on a un certain nombre de
nos collaborateurs la ligne managériale
des salariés des moniteurs qui sont
partis sur le site d'antony pour
apprendre un peu les gestuelles et
apprendre les techniques de montage
on a aussi des techniciens qui sont en
train de regarder le processus de
fabrication pour pouvoir adapter les
postes de travail sur notre site
en parallèle nous n'a fait c est ce
vendredi pour expliquer quels sont les
les mousses les mesures de
des gestes barrières qu'on va mettre en
place pour éviter que la propre agaçant
parce que être solidaire c'est une chose
mais c'est la solidarité veut dire qu'on
remplit aussi les hôpitaux c'est pas
vraiment être solidaire donc les
principes de barrières qui vont être mis
en place
ce seront des arriérés de destination
des équipes ou qui sont fournis par la
direction pour pouvoir contribuer à
cette fabrication là et puis pour être
complet sur le sujet il se félicite de
voir l'usiné psa a participé à la
production des respirateurs artificiels
est le maire de poissy à karl olive
salut dans un communiqué la démarche du
groupe implantée dans la ville
cette guerre ne se gagnera qu'en faisant
front tous ensemble en faisant nation a
affirmé l'élu yvelinois